donc qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur cet
animal quand on observe comme ça la
mission de ces enfants connaître le
triton crêté pour en devenir un eux
aussi ils participent à fréquence
grenouille et vont découvrir cet animal
protégé
c'est une espèce en voie de disparition
malheureusement comme beaucoup dans
fille bien ici mais aussi à travers le
monde et c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut
les protéger
elle est préservé et c'est pour vraiment
sensibiliser éduquer les enfants et
aussi les parents à cette protection de
ces espèces très importante et qui sont
vraiment qui évoluent dans ces milieux
et aquatiques et terrestres
si tu étais un un triton serial tirer ou
toi dans les temps là un plein d'eau la
petite main le jeu pensé par la réserve
de lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines veut faire découvrir la
nécessité de protéger les zones humides
pour conserver sa biodiversité très très
bien le monsieur il était très très bien
voilà il y avait un petit groupe laon ça
s'est bien passé avec le soleil
impeccable à il fallait faire des
mouvements avec les pattes avant et les
pattes arrière ce qu'on ait des tritons
et aider a déjà trouvé les les pâtes les
empreintes et tout ça j'essaye de donner
quelques réponses qui sait pas bien de
polluer les eaux pour les amphibiens et
tous les autres un set
les participants ont pu profiter d'une
ouverture exceptionnelle
la réserve naturelle est accessible que
quelques jours par mois dans le monde
plus de 50% des zones humides ont
disparu au cours du siècle dernier